my mother started as a first year
student at the University of North
Carolina in 1972 that would not have
been possible had she been born just a
few years earlier for most of its
history UNC was an exclusively male
institution like many universities and
while we've come an incredible long way
from their sexism is still alive and
well indeed it's living in our language
now I'm not talking about words that
were designed to denigrate women [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm talking about seemingly
innocent words words that we hear every
day
perhaps we even speak them mankind
man-made or popular here at Stanford
chairman fellow male centered words are
everywhere we're taught that all men are
created equal we man tables and use our
manpower to elect congressmen who rule
in man-made institutions oh man
we laugh but I'm really concerned with
these associations due to our
unconscious beliefs how does the
perpetual Association of male terms with
power and with strength and female turns
with insult and with weakness shape our
expectations for men and for women our
expectations of ourselves are even our
self-worth children can help us
understand just how powerful language
can be my niece Ella is five years old
she has three older brothers and I was
babysitting for them and so I asked them
what do you guys want to do tonight Ella
was silent a little later as I was
tucking her into bed she looked up to me
and she said Uncle Wynn
how come you only wanted to know what
the guys wanted to do why didn't you
care about me my heart sank of course I
wanted to hear what she had to say I
loved Ella's opinions sometimes I love
Ella the most I had never meant to
suggest that she didn't matter but
that's exactly what I had done through
my words and thank goodness she said
something to me when I had said you guys
to her she took me literally and quite
logically she felt left out how often
had she felt that way before how many of
you have ever felt that way before
excluded by language even if you knew
that that wasn't the speaker's intention
male-centered words are everywhere when
you flip the words around how many men
do you know that feel flattered to be
called a woman right Douglas Hofstadter
is a philosopher and what he does is he
replaces in a satire male based generic
words with race-based ones mankind
becomes white kind freshmen becomes
fresh
chairman becomes chair white and in this
imaginary world it becomes pretty
ridiculous that we would ever expect
people of color to feel included by
these terms or that these terms wouldn't
have real and lasting consequences
things that reflect a pretty gruesome
history but that's exactly what we do
it's what we do to women and it's what I
did to Ella of course some women and
many women do feel included by these
terms and that's entirely understandable
women have become congressmen for
example work incredibly hard to get
where they are they overcome enormous
obstacles they earn the title when women
don't feel included I've heard them
speak up and then I've watched the eye
rolls
I've listened as I get labeled
high-maintenance overly sensitive or
much worse when we use male words or
female words to insult women we
communicate a pretty disturbing message
and we communicate the same disturbing
message when we use only positive words
with male terms sociologist cheryl
Klieman explains that when you use
chairman for women yes a particular
woman can become a chairman but women as
a group cannot chairman sets the
expectation that chairmen are men and
when a woman achieves that title she's
merely an exception never the rule
rarely the expectation when we use male
based generics we erase women
linguistically symbolically we
annihilate them now there was a
visionary who I love Marilyn Frye and
she imagines all of this gender
inequality is essentially a birdcage
that traps women inside there are many
many wires to the cage one wire is the
wage gap another wire is sexual
harassment
another one is men's violence against
women and their sexist English the point
here is that there are many many wires
and these wires but no wire by itself
traps the bird inside it's all of the
wires working together in combination
that creates a prison we can break that
prison with so many wires I often get
asked why focus on language aren't there
other wires that are more important let
me be clear every wire is important
every wire deserves to be broken and
every wire that we break creates a new
opening I like to single out sexist
language for three reasons
the first reason is that everyone has
the power to break this wire it's
entirely within our control each of us
decides constantly what words were gonna
say what we're gonna type in a text
message put in an email what language
displays on our websites or goes in
official publications that we put up
there language is a choice that we make
constantly it's our choice the second
reason is that we can break this wire
right now you don't have to wait it's so
much easier to start saying you all
today than it is to close the wage gap
tomorrow so of course we should do that
too
the third reason is that gender
inclusive language is inclusive of
everyone even men it doesn't harm anyone
when you switch to inclusive terms
instead it proactively signals your
commitment to women and what more
powerful message to send I want to
acknowledge that while this solution is
really simple that doesn't make it easy
male-dominated words are everywhere
they're deeply embedded in our culture
getting rid of them requires intention
it requires unlearning it requires a
community to hold one another
accountable so let's do this together
let's stop using gendered words and
replace them with gender-neutral options
fresh
becomes first-year student chairman
becomes chair Arbuckle fellow becomes
Arbuckle coach or scholar or leader you
guys becomes you all or if you're like
me from the South y'all language is a
tool of thought it's a tool for building
community and it's a tool for breaking
bird cages each of us has the power to
create the world that we want to be in
so do we want a language that reflects
our history of excluding and diminishing
women No do we prefer a language that
aspires toward something much more
inclusive for our future for our mothers
our sisters our daughters our nieces
your decision to become a gender savvy
speaker is a decision to build this
world a world that takes women seriously
Cyril Klieman teaches [ __ ] our that
inclusive language is the resource that
each of us has at the tip of our tongues
let's start tasting its freedom today
thank you